a big night for the clark county school
district after months and months of
contention superintendent dr jesus
jarrah returning to his seat during
tonight's regular board meeting the
board fired him in october then
rescinded that decision just last month
sasha loftis joins us with more on the
agreement made between jarrah and the
board sasha
brian and kirsten some may call this the
culmination of months of turmoil all
eyes will be on dr jarrah tonight as he
attends his first ccsd board meeting in
person since he was originally
terminated by the board back in october
we obtained this agreement between dr
jesus jarrah and the ccsd board of
trustees citing better cooperation
moving forward it did shed some light on
past conflicts saying the board will
communicate about meeting agendas only
use authority as a group not a single
trustee acting alone and discuss dr
jarrah's claims of harassment the
agreement was signed by dr jarrah board
president linda cavazos irene cepeda and
evelyn garcia morales trustee daniel
ford later released this statement
saying she was quote excluded from board
attorney meetings for purportedly
violating confidentiality
we did reach out to trustee ford
regarding that and she did confirm that
she was excluded from the meeting where
the board and its attorney discussed
this agreement now in terms of the
agreement it does also state that if any
board members do not stick with this
plan they will be disciplined now of
course stay with 8 news now for the
latest as we continue to follow this
meeting tonight reporting live sasha
loftis live local now